He is the worldwide symbol of
rebellion and revolutionary struggle.
His silhouette is familiar to billions
representing the epitome of cool
antiestablishment ism.
Yet few people know the real story behind
the legends of Che Guevara and in this
week's biographics we discover the man
behind the myth to reveal an individual
whose passion for social
justice so are no bounds
and let's do it.
Guevara Della Center was born on June
the 14th 1928 and the town of Rosario
Ivan,
Tina.
It's family was aristocratic with his
father when Nestor Guevara Lynch operating
construction and ship building businesses
born premature Levy Infants Guevara
who sued, acquired the
nickname che struggled with
asthma as well as pneumonia.
His mother was the dominant
figure in his life,
teaching him to read and
write and impressing her
belief in social justice upon
him.
Jay was the oldest of five children.
The family were exposed to a wide range
of political and philosophical thoughts
with his father being friendly with
many veterans of the Spanish civil war.
The boy develops a strong interest in
sport at selling as athletics, swimming,
and rugby.
He was known for his aggressive style
of play and the mental drive to push his
body to the limit. Jay also develops
a passion for intellectual pursuits.
By the age of 10 he had become a very
good chess player in the veracious reader.
I think Avara home was overflowing with
books on a wide range of subject six
supposing him to the ideas of men
like Karl Marx, Sigmund Freud,
and Friedrich Engels k also showed a
great love for poetry and his early teens.
Che's interest in the philosophies of
great thinkers of the past that didn't to
keep a personal journal in which he
would summarize their main ideas as he
formulated his own outlook
on life at school chain.
He was confident and determined a school
nature men button as incredibly sure of
himself and totally independent in
his opinions, very dynamic, restless,
and unconventional. He acted more maturely
than many of his peers and associates.
While I'm still in high school.
He surrounded himself with university
students proving to be the intellectual
equal and showing a political insight
that often even surpass bears.
On one occasion, his university pals
edge DMZ join them in a political rally.
He replies, go out in the streets so
the police can hit us with their clubs,
nothing doing.
I'll go and demonstrate only if
you give me a gun. In later life.
Guevara made their comments.
That was certainly the case for himself
and then of 15 already knows what he
wants to die for and he is not afraid
of giving his life if he has found an
ideal which makes the sacrifice easy.
At Age 15 Guevara ideal was still
in a raw state consisting us.
We're more of a passion for equality
for all and a rejection of materialism.
Still at this age, he was more
interested in sports and politics.
You impressed everyone with
this fierce self-discipline.
His ass man made it a challenge for
him to stay on the rugby fields,
but he saw his condition as a barrier
of it could be overcome with sheer force
of will chase self-discipline
translated to his academic life as well.
After graduating from high school,
he completed a six year university
medical degree in just three years.
His aunt later recalled.
We would listen to him gasping,
studying as he lay on the
floor to ease his breathing,
but he never complains for him.
There was a challenge,
jade,
again,
his university studies at the University
of when us Aries and 1948 at the age of
20 he refused to involve himself with
the political movements against the
Peruvian government staying
focused on his studies.
He founds its rasping from academia on
the back of his 500 CC Norton motorcycle,
which he nicknames lap Ponderosa meaning
the mighty one. Yeah, it's chase.
First major excursion was
actually on the back of a bicycle,
one that he had fitted a small motor
team in 1950 he embarks on a solo track
across northern Argentina that would
see in pedaling some 2,800 miles a year
later,
he paired up with a university friends,
Alberto Grenada for a massive motorcycle
track across the South American
continents.
The two men traveled from one location
to another finding work as laborers as
they went at some pub. Lou, they
volunteered to work in a leper colony.
It was here.
Let's give our recalled.
Seeing the most impressive
example of solidarity and loyalty,
and this was among men who
had nothing materially.
He was also deeply affected by the intense
poverty that he saw in every corner
of the continents.
In his minds,
this was an indictment of the feeling
capitalist system throughout the 5,000
mile excursion Guevara. I kept a journal
in which he recorded his experiences.
These were later published as a book
which was entitled the Motorcycle Diaries
in the 1990s the motorcycle journey
proved to be a great turning points in
Guevaras life in 1960 he
wrote the following because
of the conditions in which
I traveled. I came into close contact
with poverty and hunger and disease.
I discovered that I was unable to cure
sick children through lack of means,
and they saw the degradation of under
nourishment and constant repression.
In this way.
I began to realize that there was another
thing that was as important as being a
famous researcher or making a great
contribution to medical science,
and that was to help people,
his experiences over the
course of his travels. Also,
it proven to Guevara that he could exist.
On very little.
He had the ability to push himself
forward despite food, water,
sleep or anything
materially these qualities,
what to make him an extremely effective
guerilla fighter Guevara and taken a
year sabbatical from his university
degree to embark upon his attic journey
returning.
He threw himself into his studies
graduating in 1953 to officially become a
doctor two months later,
however,
he abandons this career and
stepped into the political arena
with another friends, Carlos for
rec. Avara headed for Bolivia.
The country had just come under
his first reformed governments.
The big issue was the
nationalization of the countries.
10 lines or revolution was forming,
but che refused to be drawn in stating
that the revolutionaries were not
concerned with addressing
the causes of injustice,
but we're merely tinkering with the
effects rejecting the revolutionary
movements in Bolivia. Jay and
Carlos headed for Peru. Yeah.
They found that they were unable to
open any kinds of communication with the
down fraud, an Indian Sioux
according to Farrah standards,
lips as tight and for bidding as a
vice that refuse to to reply to our
questions. Still the Peruvian
border guards web. Sure.
That the two foreign upstarts sweat
forming some sort of agrarian revolution
from Peru. They traveled to Guatemala.
Yeah, I revolution had just taken pace.
Jay have not yet fully
developed a Marxist philosophy,
but he felt a personal responsibility
to help the downtrodden.
His challenge was to find a
workable way in order to do this,
the new revolutionary
government in Guatemala,
it was led by Hacobo Arbenz who had
managed to pull together a group of young
army officers and intellectuals.
As Jay arrived on the scene, I'll,
this was in the process of redistributing
lands that had been nationalized from
the American United Fruit company. That
hasn't work. It's the ever present.
Fear was that this would provoke a
counterrevolution revolution that would be
backed by the Americans.
Jay wanted to work as a doctor for the
Guatemalans in the jungles of Bhutan.
However, he would be required to
join the Guatemalan Labour party,
which was another name for
the local communist party.
She refuse to join painting that he
was a revolutionary and that that
designation superseded any political
affiliations of the Arbenz government only
lasted a year due to the fear and
American intervention becoming a reality.
The CIA trained and finance day
revolution, regrouping, managed,
do you asked the sitting government
courts in the middle of it all was Che
Guevara who commented,
and we are like the Spanish republic
betrayed from within and without,
but we did not for with the same dignity.
Finally,
he committed himself to revolution
reaction. Yet despite his best efforts,
he could not rally the Guatemalan people
for a consolidated defense. In the ends.
Arbenz weekly resigned.
She had been marked for execution by the
incoming regime and was forced to flee
to the Argentinian embassy where he
was holed up for almost two months.
His experiences in Guatemala Convinced
Chafe at America was the great enemy of
worldwide freedom and that capitalism
was holding people in a state of
subjugation.
It was at this point is that he began
to seriously study the of Marx and Lenin
from Argentina Che made from Mexico
where he began to develop his skills as a
revolutionary.
In 1955 he met Fidel Castro,
who had been exiled from
Cuba after a failed coup,
Castro was actively looking
for revolutionaries do
join a second attempt to
overthrow the regime of full Henslow.
Battista shaved like 20 herds and
he enthusiastically signed up.
The Cuban revolutionaries hadn't even
left Mexican show us when they were
intercepted by Mexican intelligence
services and thrown in prison.
It was Jay's first
experience of incarceration,
the screens of his fellow inmates as
they were being beaten and immersed in
water.
It had a powerful impact on Castro,
though he was able to exert influence
through the Russian embassy that got all
of the men released from 1956 the small
band of men were undergoing guerrilla
warfare training on the
Rancho San Miguel Halco.
Che proved to be the outstanding
students among the group despite his ever
present asthma, the att
revolutionaries, they sit out for Cuba.
On November the 25th 1956 on board
a dilapidated yacht called grandma.
None of the men onboard.
We're sailors and they all got seasick
with most of the suppliers being lost in
a storm.
They finally landed in a swampy area
that led to a mountain range in the south
east of Cuba for the next few weeks.
They wandered around somewhat aimlessly.
They found a guide,
but he betrayed them to Battista's forces.
The rebels were surrounded as they lounged
around in the jungle with their boots
off and weapons laid aside in the ensuing
fast on all but 12 of Castro's man,
they were wiped out. Castro,
he was wounded in the neck,
but he managed to escape with
four of his comrades. In doing so,
he had to make a fateful choice of this.
He later wrote.
This was perhaps the first time I had
to choose between my education for
medicine and my duty as
a revolutionary soldier.
As my feet were a pack full of medicines
and the cartridge box together,
they were too heavy to carry.
I chose the cartridge box
leaving behind the Madsen pack.
J led his group to the Sierra, my strat
and meet up with any other survivors.
He used what he thought was
the north star to guide him,
but it was actually another star runs.
The group got hopelessly lost.
They eventually arrived
at the meeting place.
By sheer luck for the next few weeks,
the man had to rely on the generosity
of local peasants just to survive.
It was a small victory in the group
struggle to enlarge their numbers as they
settled into life in the
Sierra Maestra Mountains,
though few peasants join the rebellion,
they did build up a network
of sympathizes and he,
he showed any signs of
allegiance to the Patista.
Governments were put to death
often on the orders of Guevara.
It was during this time
that chain develops the cold
ruthlessness that he felt
was necessary to the makeup of a
revolutionary over the next two years.
He was to order the deaths of hundreds
of Patista followers by May of 1957 the
guerrilla force said the rebuilt to about
80 men and they had built a sizeable
cache of weapons they overcame than
other army barracks sins. Before long.
The entire Sierra Maestra region
has become a liberated zone,
whether he's does forces fear to go
during this time, that red alarm,
he had transformed itself from something
of a clueless mob to an actual season
to guerrilla force.
This was almost entirely due to the
training and the guidance of Che Guevara.
Castro had made him a commandant second
in rank only to himself as well as
training the men in fighting tactics.
He also established a field hospital,
the tailor's shop bakery,
and a printing shop.
You've are also set up a radio station
so that the rebels could speak directly
to the peasant population.
As a result of his prominent work at
the core of the red alarm egg Avara,
his name came to the attention of the
authorities being mentioned in the same
breath as the Castro brothers as an
enemy of the state within the group.
He also gone at his own loyal following
and in time he would become a threat to
Fidel himself. By the end of autumn
1958 the rebel force had one,
a series of victories
in the south of Cuba.
This precipitated Che's Long March
towards Havana during which is small but
determined forced travel by night and
attack to the villages and towns that they
encountered along the way during the day.
The ultimate objective was to gain
control of the province of last vs
effectively cutting Cuba and half.
Che proved himself to be
a brilliant tactician.
He perfected the art of setting up a
rule base is expanding them until a town
fell and then isolating cities and
squeezing the resistance sounds of it.
The final attack on the provinces
Capitol of Santa Clara involved a suicide
squad attack that soar as men outnumbered
10 to one the victory that resulted
was the most decisive battle in the
entire revolution with a rebel victory at
Santa Clara and the rebels heading
for the Capitol for Hensdale.
Battista knew the game was up.
He abandoned the country,
and on the 1st of January,
1959 headed for the Dominican Republic
with an alleged fortune of $300 million.
The next day, Jay enter Devonna like
a conquering hero. Fidel the rive.
Six days later to proclaim
there's a new era had begun.
The men who now inherited the governments
of Cuba where predominantly uneducated
and ill prepared for the task.
The clear exception was Che Guevara.
While he had no direct
governmental experience,
he was a university graduates who
were steeped in philosophical thought.
Further during the time in the mountains,
he had proven his ability
to organize Madden.
Surely organizing a country wouldn't
be much more difficult. As a result,
she became the brains of the new
governments for the next six years.
He remained in Cuba implementing his
own form of guerrilla governments.
His first focus was to shift Cuba from
an agrarian to an industrial society.
In order to become independent
from foreign imperialists,
Cuba had to become self sufficient.
J spoke less about the peasantry
and more about the urban worker.
In 1961 he was appointed minister of
Industry and instituted a program of
converting agricultural
implements into raw materials.
Too many people by such policies chain,
he was deserted.
The peasant class shape never appreciated
the complexity and its financial
resources that we needed
to set up new industries.
The factories that resulted ended up
producing goods that were of low quality
and high price.
By the end of 1964 Guevara had established
himself as an international expert on
revolution reaction. During a three
month world tour. He visited China,
North Korea, Algiers, Ghana, Tanzania,
and a few other countries espousing his
anticapitalist ideology and claiming
that the Cuban revolution was something
spiritual that would transcend all
boarders.
At the beginning of 1965 Guevara went
to the Congo to lend his support to the
revolutionary struggle
there for seven months.
He lands in Afro Cuban force of
about a hundred men. However,
his movements were constantly monitored
by the Kongo national army and the
American CIA and he was
unable to make any traction.
After spending time in Exxon at
the Cuban embassy in Dar es Salaam,
Jay quietly returned to Cuba.
Then in October,
1966 he slipped into Bolivia that he
believed that he could ferment an uprising
that would lead to the eventual overthrow
of imperialism throughout all of Latin
America during his time
in Bolivia Guevara cabs,
a detailed daily account
of his experiences which
had been published as the
Bolivian diaries via count reveals that
the specter of death was ever presence.
Though it is clear that he didn't
go to Bolivia wanting to get killed,
he was well aware for the odds of emerging
from the struggle alive were slim at
best. J and the Cubans who came with him
were not welcomed with open arms by fee
Bolivian revolutionaries.
The Bolivian Indians,
they distrusted the Cubans
as foreign white men.
As a result during the entire 11 months,
Che was unable to recruit a
single Bolivian Indian too
is cause Jay divided his
small rebel group into two divisions.
He likes the decisiveness and degression
of the actions that he had during the
Cuban revolution.
He was also suffering physically at
this point with his asthmatic bounce,
becoming chronic,
still his resolve to go on and never
wanes as long as he could breathe.
You could fight.
Each rebel division was systematically
hunted down by the Bolivian forces.
On October the seventh 1967 and informants
led Bolivian special forces troops to
Castries camp in the euro ravine.
Almost 2000 soldiers surrounded the
camp and moved in for the kill ball,
but 10 men were killed.
Guevara throw up his hands and he yelled,
do not shoot. I am Che Guevara and I
am worth more to you alive and debt.
They were into. Jay was captured bounds
and taken to a nearby school house.
Attempts to interrogate and failed.
As he refused to speak.
One of the Bolivian soldiers present
recalled that Jay held his head high,
looked very one straight in the eye
and asked only for something to smoke.
A pipe was handed to j and d contently
puffed on it until they Bolivian officer
entered the room and
grabbed it from his mouth.
In response Guevara kicked out at the
officer on the morning of October,
the Ninth Guevara requested an
audience with the local school teacher.
The young woman was summons
and she listened respectfully.
As Che brought our attention to the
dilapidated condition of a school room and
contrasted it to the lavish conditions
which government officials enjoyed.
He told her that is what
he was fighting for,
the teacher Judy Cortez liter related,
that she could not meet Che's gays
because it was unbearable piercing and so
tranquil Zune.
The news came through the Bolivian
President Renée baryons Os had ordered the
death of Che Guevara before the execution.
The soldiers paraded him outside the
school room and took photos with them.
Then it was taken back inside.
Whereas execution or entered Guevara
stood as he spoke the last words to his
killer. I know you've come
to kill me, shoot coward,
you are only going to kill a man.
The assassin,
a soldier named Mario Tara and then
opened fire hitting che and the arms and
legs.
He was careful to inflict wounds in such
a way that the story could be told that
che was killed during a firefight.
The revolutionary icon was pronounced
dead at 1:10 PM on October the ninth 1968
the manner of his death created a
mater of the substance of his life,
created a legend as strong
today as it ever was.
So I really hope you found that
video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button
below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos like this
every Monday and every Thursday,
and when you are hitting that subscribe
button and you hit that bell as well,
because that means you will get
notifications. If you just subscribed,
you might a year might not. Who
knows? So do click that as well.
And as always,
thank you for watching.